In this series and we surprise you and you strip away all the complexity
and hard graphed and teach you how to cook amazing food standing on your head
"That is amazing! incredibly tender"
from the Kitchen Novice, to the budding chef
i'm going to give you the confidence, the recipes  and the insider knowledge to make you a much better cook.
"slide around"
"waste nothing!"
I've been cooking in professional kitchens for over 25 years
I've been taught by some of the best chefs in the world and in turn I've taught some of the best
Now I'm gonna show you some simple and accessible recipes for fantastic food that you can easily cook at home
"mmm, incredible"
I'll be holding you by the hand it gets better and better and better
Teaching you everything from how to cook with chili and spice, to baking, real fast food and my ultimate feast recipes
This is the only cookery course you'll ever need
Welcome to my ultimate cookery course. Back with cooking tips information and 100 recipes to stake your life on.
The frying pan is one of your best friends
it's so versatile in the kitchen learning to use it with these is a must and I'm gonna show you how
First up my delicious pan-fried pork chops with sweet and sour peppers
Whether it's in the restaurant or even at home
One of my golden rules for producing fantastic food is learning to cook with confidence
This recipe is so straightforward but tastes absolutely amazing
Pan on, get that nice and hot
You think of the sort of density of a pork chop how it needs a little bit of help
Sweet sound peppers go brilliantly well
First slice the peppers. That's the flat side of the pepper. So stand it up
Try to slice a pepper on the side is a nightmare. There's the center start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an orange all the way around and
down
And look this one
Now place the pepper down
three-finger rule one finger in front, two behind
Pinkie holding it down thumb holding it nice and flat, the flatter the vegetables, the more confident you are when you slice so,
Don't worry about the speed
Just let the knife do the work and take your time
Speed = cuts. The most important thing is to get your technique right.
red onion
Now sweet sour peppers, olive oil in
I'm going to sauté them which is just the chef's term for shallow-fried on a high heat for maximum taste
Salt and pepper, "add a tablespoon of sugar;" sugar helps to break down the peppers quicker
But caramelize the onions find them in a frying pan. Perfect
they're one of those sort of basic essential tools of any kitchen because it's so multi-purpose great for sautéing
tossing great for cooking fish and meat
push away and pull back, push away and pull back, that hissing is something you need to hear constantly because
The minute that's gone your peppers and your onions start to boil and you really want them to sauté.
You now start to see glistening in a way that it's starting to caramelize, sugar is working usefully
That's ready for the red wine vinegar
in
Smells incredible it helps to stain the peppers as well. look at the glaze now, do you see the sugar
has worked it's magic. Turn down the gas and add a couple of table spoons of
Extra-virgin olive oil. Let them stew for two to three minutes.
Now I want to make the peppers nice and light and sort of sweet aromatic
Just roll the basil almost like a big cigar
slice
Basil in and then literally cook it out for 30 seconds and then take them off.
Beautiful
Okay, pan back on
And now for pork chops, I wanna make sure they don't curl up in the pan. They start curling up in the pan
they're gonna cook unevenly. A few simple cuts through the Rhine means the Chop stays flat and cooks evenly
Point the knife down
flip through. Season them beautifully
nice large
shards of pepper punch that through lightly guaranteed that seasoning
is gonna stay there, hot pan, a touch of garlic and a touch of thyme.
and the garlic
Take a cup of cloves
Don't peel it. Don't chop it just knife on
Crush it
Olive oil in
just starting to smoke top of the chop in lay away from
Nice
Keep that heat in the pan, put the garlic in there early a nice fragrant bunch of thyme
see how the pork is staying nice and flat turn it over. Look at that, beautiful.
I want a little bit of thyme underneath there.
Start squeezing that garlic out, I what the flavour coming out
Butter in
thin slices of butter tilt the pan and baste
So I'm sort of speeding up the cooking process at the same time
I'm keeping the pork chop, really nice and moist and now look at the color that butter
look at that butter, it's almost like a nut brown.
Check the color on the other side, beautiful.
When that thick between 1/2 to 4 minutes each size, 30 seconds from now they will be medium
They're gonna be medium. So I'm gonna take them out and let them rest
The secret to perfectly moist pork chops is letting them rest almost as long as they're cooked in the pan
a nice spoon
of these peppers basil smells
Incredible did that garlic on there be generous with that vinaigrette from the pepper because it really is incredible
Do two things simple like that pork and peppers
And your confidence is going to shoot through the roof a stunning pork chop with sweet sour peppers
The frying pan is so simple, but incredibly useful with this one pan, you can make a million different dishes
The more you cook with your frying pan, the more your confidence will grow
Here are three my favorite easy pan-fried dishes
First up pan-fried scallops with crunchy apple salad
Get a frying pan smoking hot, essential for quick pan frying add olive oil
Then season scallops with salt and pepper
Starting at the top put clockwise into the pan. So, you know which one to turn first?
Scallops have firm white sweet flesh and cook in minutes
Next salad, lamb's lettuce, matchsticks of apple
Seasoning, lemon (zest and juice)
Add Olive Oil then toss
Turn the scallops when Golden, going clockwise around the pan
Then squeeze in lemon juice and give the pan a shake
Finish with lemon zest
Ready in under ten minutes, my first pan fried dish = scallops with crunchy apple salad
My next super simple pan-fried recipe is... chicken and chicory in masala sauce
Season the chicken breasts, add to hot olive oil skin-side down lay away from you to stop the oil splashing
Sliced chicory, this versatile vegetable can be red or white; has a lovely bitter taste and is great cooked or raw
Crush a clove of garlic and add, then sprigs of thyme
When the chicken skin is crisp turnover, along with the chicory
For the sauce and masala (a sweet fortified wine from Sicily)
Then 150 ml of chicken stock
To make the sauce wander too rich in glossy and butter and simmer for 10 minutes
Plate up and spoon over the sauce, cooked in under 20 minutes, chicken and chicory in masala sauce
My final dish cooked in the versatile frying pan is... sea bream with tomato and herb salsa
Fry phyllis of sea bream skin side down in hot olive oil
If they buckle up, press gently down for perfect even cooking, then season
Sea bream has firm white flesh. Perfect for pan frying
Next the salsa
heat olive oil add half cherry tomatoes pitted black olives and season
After a minute on a low heat add coriander, basil and lemon
Combine and leave to infuse
As a seabream cooks it goes opaque
When it's 2/3 from the top turnover
Bast, fry, and it's done
Seabream with tomato and herb salsa ready in under 15 minutes
One pan three simple impressive and absolutely delicious dishes; "beautiful"
Coming up on my ultimate cookery course
along with a hundred recipes to stake your life on I'm gonna give you a hundred quick cooking tips to make your life in the
kitchen easier
First up, how to keep your knives sharp
It's far harder working in the kitchen with a blunt knife than it is with a sharp knife the secret behind keeping a sharp knife
Sharpen it before and every time you use it first grip the steel feel really comfortable about holding still imagine
You're holding a tennis racket or you're playing squash. you've got to be really comfortable with it
Now 45 degrees confident grip confident grip with a knife
This is the butt of the steel really important to keep your fingers behind that you never grip a steel with your fingers over that
Because the knife comes back in you just lost a finger. It's always grip behind
Nice long strokes so we get the whole of the blade over
the Steel
Stroke and we start from the bottom to the top so
there, across
slow strokes over the top of the steel and then come back in beneath, back in beneath
It is so dangerous working in the kitchen with a blunt knife
You can cause so much damage working with a sharp knife is ten times quicker more efficient, now
That's ready to start chopping
To stop your chopping board rocking or slipping a great tip is to simply wet a kitchen cloth
kitchen paper or tea towel and place it underneath
Now you can chop with confidence
My next top tip is get the most out of your humble veg peeler
It's brilliant for slicing ultra-thin ribbons of veg perfect for Asian dishes
Great for making long delicate parmesan shavings to top soups and salads
It also makes wonderful chocolate curls
Your Peppermill is more versatile than you might think tighten the top screw to get finely ground pepper ideal for soups and sauces
For general seasoning. You want it medium ground to set the screw to medium-ground and loosen it right off for coarse pepper
perfect for steaks and fish
Peeling garlic.
the one clove simply bash it with the back of a knife and the skin comes off easily
For a whole head crush, separate into a bowl,
Cover and shake hard for about ten seconds then simply pick out the peeled cloves
Coming up on my ultimate cookery course
more great cooking tips
Just hold it down and your fingers on there's a really nice way of taking off all those nice fragrant little thyme flowers
how to shop for the best ingredients
"The skin is a nice white color
And it smells like a fresh chickeny smell."
and a stunning roast chicken recipe to stake your life on
This is my ultimate cookery course, 100 recipes to stake your life on I'll be showing you a roast chicken recipe to die for
Hold the drum the sliced straight through
But first like any good chef. I'm always looking to get great ingredients at the right price
My shopping mantra is simple first rely on your senses. Make sure whatever you're buying
It looks smells and really feels good. And if you get the chance taste it before you buy it
Second is to recognize that knowledge is crucial the more
You know about where your ingredients come from and how they are produced, the better so
asked lots of questions and learn.
You're never too old to learn from experts and when it comes to buying great birds
The one person knows what to look for is award-winning fifth-generation master Butcher, Danny Lydgate
"Poultry is a great meat because there's many different types of birds"
"It's worth tasting. The variation of flavors between different first types of birds is massive."
"Turkeys are a great lean meat that's available all year-round and not just for Christmas. Anybody who's worried about eating fatty meats."
" It's a really healthy, flavorsome meal"
"Game birds people don't try them often enough. Once they're shot, they're hung up for a little while (a few days"
"at least) it means the meats going to be more tender all adds of flavor to the birds"
"We've got a wood pigeon and a red leg Partridge both really good and cook really quickly"
"When you're buying a chicken some of things to look out for is obviously the smell"
"And when you're smelling a good quality chicken"
"You can tell the difference the skins are nice white color and it smells like a fresh chickeny smell"
"When you're buying from a good butcher, you'll find you tend to get the giblets as well"
"Which is basically the neck and other organs. This is great for making gravy"
"Once you have cooked it, you can use all the offcuts for other things stir Fry's Curry's pass"
"The dishes save the bones use the bones for stocks and soups they're really packed full of flavor"
And remember there are lots of different breeds of chicken all have different characteristics and flavors
So shop around and find the ones you love here are three of my all-time favorites.
The label Anglais these come from an old British breed. They've got smaller breasts, but the meat is delicious
The Black Leg a fantastic French variety succulent with bags of flavor and really meaty thighs and
The Poulet De Bresse. This is the rolls-royce of chickens. Rich gamey and delicious one for special occasions
"I think people should maybe try and buy less meat but aim for the best quality"
"You're only going to get out what you put in by putting the best quality into a dish. You're going to get the best results"
No matter how seasoned the chef you are, there are always new ingredients and recipes to get fired up about
So if a tired old recipe is getting you down spice it up with fresh ideas and flavors
My next recipe is an old classic roast chicken, but with a simple twist, it takes on a new life and is guaranteed to impress
one of the things I love about cooking and that keeps me excited after 25 years behind the stove is
That there's always something new to learn every day new ingredients, new techniques and new cuisines
Start off with a stuffing
it's amazing how
Exciting a stuffed roast chicken can be because it keeps the chicken incredibly moist and gives a delicious texture
Inside the bird. I'm going to start off with cured sorriso. This is a traditional Spanish sausage, and it's
garlicky spicy
Incredibly meaty that gives a little bit of sort of richness to the stuffing. Get our sorriso in.
Start cooking that down and get all those oils out a touch of olive oil in there to get it going. Right onions
Chopped
Add the onions to the Sorriso and in a matter of seconds, they'll change color as they soak up all the flavor
That lovely spiciness has been stolen from that sausage and now the onions smell incredible
garlic
Garlic in
Fresh thyme just hold it down and put your fingers on there. It's really nice why I've taken off all those nice fragrant little thyme flowers
You can hear it crackling in the background
These are cannellini beans. They're waxy, very soft
And so delicious but very dense, but for stuffing they're so robust. Nothing breaks down. Drain them off
In
They're going to take on all that juice as well from the sorriso. I'm going to season now because if they dense so need some help
That looks like it's a dish on its own;  good enough to eat now.
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
tomatoes half tried
in
That sweetens up
The stuffing
beautiful
The stuffing is ready. Look at the color of everything, that Spanish looks delicious
now
stuffing the chicken
I like taking off these little knuckles as the chicken cooks the skin stretches over the bone
You can get a really nice drum and take off those little wing tips as well
salt and pepper
So important
Now your stuffing we go right inside, which you can
Push it down. This really helps to cook the bird evenly because you're pushing out all the empty spaces in the carcass
And take a nice large lemon, push the lemon in
Pick up the parcels nose, put the skin over, olive oil on top
Salt and pepper
Teaspoon of paprika
Sprinkle it on and then put your hands
Sort of rub that in. You see what the paprika is doing to the chicken put this like sweet
Spicy marinade its not even roasted yet, but it looks delicious
400 ml of wine while same quantity of water that helps the chicken to steam
chicken in
Be generous with the thyme sprigs
Make sure the foil is folded tightly around the roasting tray. So the chicken's steams in the oven keeping it moist and juicy
into the oven
Cook for 1 hour at 180 degrees with the foil on.
nice.
Take it out and remove the foil lid then give it another 30 minutes to crisp up that skin
Look at that!
It's so important to make sure you tear that tinfoil off with half an hour to go
Beautiful. Pierce that open, squeeze it in that delicious gravy. Mix that into the tray
And sieve that
That's a really nice fragrant lemony spiced roasting juices to finish
Before we cut up the chicken take out that amazing stuffing
Mm-hmm
Incredible I'd have that with chicken and potatoes any day; and then just get your chicken roasting juices
Now to cut the chicken up.
Hold the drum and slice straight through
And there's a wonderful drum and a thigh through the wishbone
Off
slice with the point at an angle so you can see the texture that
amazing roast chicken
Just take my cooking juices. I just want to give a nice sort of lemony flavor
over my chicken and there you go
a delicious, very charming, stuffed roast chicken
Follow my ultimate cookery course crammed with key lessons
Top tips and a hundred recipes to stake your life on and you'll literally be cooking yourself into a better chef
Many of these amazing recipes are on my app. Please check out the App Store for details.
Go on get cooking!